HE WILL JOIN US LATER
TONIGHT ALONG WITH JOE
DIGENOVA.
FIRST, JOINING US NOW OUR
TOP STORY FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR JASON CHAFFETZ.
I AM HOLDING THIS IN MY
HAND.
THIS WAS A BRILLIANT IDEA,
10 THINGS CONGRESS SHOULD DO
BUT WON'T.
AND I READ THIS AND I AM
SAYING WHY WOULDN'T THEY,
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF
EVERYTHING THAT I JUST LAID
OUT THAT THE PRESIDENT IS
DOING, TROOPS TO THE BORDER,
IS HE HELPING ON HEALTHCARE,
IS HE GOING TO GO BACK TO
THE OMNIBUS BILL.
HE IS DOING WHAT HE CAN ON
HIS OWN.
WHY DON'T THE REPUBLICANS
WANT TO DO THESE THINGS?
>> DONALD TRUMP WANTS TO
PLAY OFFENSE.
I CAN TELL YOU HAVING LEFT
CONGRESS ABOUT TWO WEEKS
AFTER, THERE IS A WHOLE NEW
CLARITY THAT SETTLES DOWN ON
YOU.
UNTIL REPUBLICANS, WHO HAVE
BEEN GIVEN THE MANTEL OF
POWER, THEY WERE ELECTED AND
PUT INTO OFFICE TO GET
THINGS DONE, UNTIL THEY
ACTUALLY PLAY OFFENSE, GUESS
WHAT, THEY WILL BE ON THE
RECEIVING END OF ATTACKS.
>> Sean: IF THEY WOULD TOO
THESE SIMPLE THINGS, FULLY
FUND THE BORDER WALL AND
BEGIN THE CONSTRUCTION, THE
MONEY IS THERE I STILL THINK
THE PRESIDENT CAN GET IT
FROM THE DODD.
IF
DOD.
REPEAL OBAMACARE.
WHY DO I BELIEVE THAT'S GOOD
POLITICS AND EVERYONE IS
WORRIED ABOUT THE BLUE WAVE
IN 2018.
THAT WOULD MITIGATE THE BLUE
WAVE.
>> JUST DO WHAT THEY SAID
THEY WERE GOING TO DO AND DO
IT IN PROACTIVE WAY.
JIM JORDAN TALKS ABOUT IT.
THIS IS WHAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ELECTED US TO DO.
LET'S TRY IT AND SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
>> Sean: I SEE HILLARY
CLINTON FIXED THE PRIMARY.
MAYBE I'M THE ONLY PERSONAL
IN THE WORLD WHO CARES ABOUT
BERNIE SANDERS SUPPORTERS.
THAT'S KIND OF CORRUPT.
OKAY, HILLARY CLINTON, SHE
DELETES 33,000 EMAILS.
SHE ACID WASHES THE HARD
DRIVE.
BLEACH BIT.
THEN SHE TAKES HAMMERS OR
HAS PEOPLE TAKING HAMMERS
AND BUSTING UP THESE
DEVICES.
THEN THE FIX IS IN WITH